all right let's see basically I know
like people are used to like really
polished presentations where people kind
of like to have their stick down and
everything and the problem is I just
spent like three days in a car with my
dogs driving here from Colorado and the
they're not really good
conversationalist so you just start
running these tracks in your head and
you start thinking about all these
things and so when I stand up I just
have this spewed it just wants to like
come out this it's all been pent up over
the last three days in this car and it
was a great Drive and basically the
other issue that I have is I feel like I
mean I'm literally since the first of
September I've just been on the road
doing stand-up and I'm just like pooped
on the one hand and on the other hand I
can't tell you how just like pumps and
excited I am about all this stuff right
because there is just so much happening
all over the world around all of these
same issues that it's really stunning
and I think it's a it's a really
reflection about the hell did much
traction this stuff is really getting
and it's also I think really really easy
to lose perspective on what it is this
is all about fundamentally for me I
think I I first started like confronting
this this dissonance in my own life when
I was teaching at Harvard and living in
San Francisco and community to Boston on
a regular basis to teach right and I
found myself like in the jet looking out
the window at the Rockies and the desert
and all this stuff for the first third
of my flight and then the last two
thirds from like the Front Range into
Boston I do emails and I'd read and I do
all this kind of stuff right
and Michael sticked is about like value
like the whole nature of value and how
to maximize that through our
organizations and our capital and our
you know our lives and our community
isn't gonna and I had I had to kind of
confront this reality that in my own
life I had this major disconnect right
between like what I was doing and how I
was living and what I was talking about
and writing about and promoting as a
practice and so I resigned my
appointment at Harvard which is kind of
a funny conversation to have because you
got the feeling they don't have that
conversation Berg often and I basically
decided I wanted to go hike and I wanted
to just get get out and get away from a
lot of that and so about five years ago
they started living half-time in the
Rockies and then about a year and a half
ago I sold my house here it's
francisco and now all I do is just kind
of like work there and basically I think
it's important to understand what
perspective consists of right and I'm
sure that I haven't really done a lot of
major research on any of those sorting
like that but you just thought to top my
head I'm thinking that perspective is
basically a function of where you have
kind of from where you've been and how
you understand where you're going and
you put those three elements together
and that places you in a certain kind of
point in time with a sense of what is
and my perspective of what is it's just
getting like whipsawed all over the
place these days because it's
simultaneously this is basically a
saddle mountain lake looking up into the
park in this Mount Ida this is where I
walk my dogs like every afternoon okay
and it's just great it's like a really
great place to be and it's been a really
interesting thing because I do as Tracy
was saying I sit there in the morning
I'll have like a three-hour conference
call but somebody in Lake Geneva and
somebody in South African Saudi else
they're about like you know structuring
capital in order to drive multiple
returns or so like that and then you
walk out the back door and there's like
a bull moose standing there looking at
you and you're kind of like yeah it's
just like phenomenal how this is all
happening so where I've been is Tracy
kind of alluded to I have this really
kind of weird thing where my background
is basically in social work and I think
of myself as a social worker whose
career is just been horribly astray
basically it's none of my problem and so
I had this whole kind of social Social
Work career track that ran through my
30s and I reached this point where I
kind of having having been the founding
director of Larkin Street youth center I
kind of woke up and I realized that I
was I was like I was this cool in the
poverty industry right that my job as a
social worker wasn't actually to change
anything it was really to kind of
provide services and keep poor people
like content you know and there was just
some dissonance for me
it's hers of that I actually like wanted
to do something right and thought that's
what this was all about and so I did a
lateral ejection on my career track and
through some weird kind of connections
ended up working with George Roberts of
KKR founding partner KKR and basically
started doing all this stuff around what
would it look like and this is like 8990
what would it look like to take business
acumen and practice and technique and
try to drive a community or social
agenda with that through leveraging
philanthropic capital into market-based
enterprises that were run by nonprofit
organizations to employ homeless people
right so you're talking like
fundamentally like right in the middle
of this rip and so that set up a whole
bunch of other things we could talk
about and and then again it kind of got
to this stage where I ended up writing
about this stuff because George and I
were in this meeting about five years
into this things guy put like seven
million dollars into this initiative and
we're talking about this and he was like
well you know I know the names of some
of these uh these business managers I
see that we're doing good things this is
really a great initiative everybody
tells me this is really great but I just
don't really know why what is this that
we're really doing what are we really
happy right and it occurred to me on
stick and Jesus I mean this guy spent
seven million dollars he doesn't know
what he bought this is a problem for me
it's the head of this thing right and so
we basically step back then we took
about six months and we wrote a book
one hundred four hundred and seventeen
page book called the new social
entrepreneur we released online in a
hardcopy in 96 we kind of teed up a lot
of this thinking around this stuff and
so as you had the tech folks come on
board in the late 90s with all they're
kind of like well we created a
revolution in technology and now we're
going to create a revolution in
education right and so they all kind of
weighed in and it was really easy to
look good then because there wasn't that
much would have been written at that
point so it's kind of like the fact that
you're using these words and language
and tools you kind of stood out and so
that's how I ended up at Harvard because
they wanted me to comment them and teach
and do more writing and things like that
and I left that and Stanford was like
well the commute from San Francisco to
Palo Alto is a lot better than let's go
to Boston so would you come on board
there and so I ended up doing more of
the stuff but simply like as an academic
kind of accidental
because I don't have a PhD I'm not
really on any kind of a tenure track I
don't really care about the Academy but
I think that the trick is there is
knowledge and there is experience and
there is learning that's evolving and
morphine out and we're not doing a good
enough job tracking that and
communicating it and actually kind of
failing forward I see a lot of people
kind of like replicating other people's
mistakes that if they would just like
stop and integrate some of the knowledge
that's already out there we could do a
lot better but any of that and so this
is kind of where I'm at so I'm trying to
figure out for myself how do you put all
this stuff together how do you
understand conceptually what the nature
of value fundamentally is about how do
you look at the world then and drive
that insight into institutions that
really at their core are having problems
maximizing their full value potential
and then how do you think about the
capital it's it's on the other side of
those institutions and how you structure
various types of capital this is kind of
like what we'll go into but that's kind
of like where I am right now but
ultimately what I'm really interested in
is this gonna come up baby there we go
is this because at the end of the day
this is basically from the Hubble Space
Telescope this is like some sort of
cosmic dust flowers and they're like
that and up but I think it's really
really important then we just kind of
pause and think about the fact that this
is really where we all came from
everything here they are our energy this
everything comes from the stars and
ultimately whatever your kind of
personal spiritual beliefs may be this
is kinda also where we're gonna return
and everything in between is just like
you know like how you are and what you
did and the legacy that you lead you
know and how we think about that and for
me I really kind of reached a point
where I mean you can start X number of
businesses and you can start so many
organizations and you can promote your
career and you can be interviewed and
you can have all this stuff which kind
of shows that you live but at the end of
the day in your own gut if you're not
really really connected to fundamentally
what is the basic core value that you're
trying to create a maximize in all parts
of your life none of that stuff is
and so and that's more kind of like what
I'm kind of grapple with and so what I
was thinking about coming and talking at
the net impact event I mean this is the
issues that I think we need to keep in
mind because it's so easy to get into
the career track and to get committed to
certain agendas and you get kind of like
bought into the process and sometimes
you just need to remember that the
career and the organization's and all
that stuff is great but at the end of
the day you got it as a list and be
really really keyed in on your core
value that you're trying to create and
so that's kind of why I've kind of taken
this sideways cut on this presentation
is it you know I want to talk about the
nature of value when I talked about
capital want to talk about organizations
but at the end of the day the reason
that we're doing this is because we're
all kind of like part of this parade and
I think that we all are in different
parts of the parade carrying different
banners and things but at the end of the
day it's not about the part of the
parade or how we identify it's about the
movement forward and about what we
represent and create through the process
of where have you live so when we think
about value what we usually do is kind
of approach it like this right then so
you got your standard kind of economic
value thing and you got your social
environmental value thing going that way
and we in essence have bought into this
idea that you can have like for profits
up here organizationally then you can
have nonprofits down there and you can
have foundations down here in terms of
asset management and capital providers
and you can have investment banking
institutions up there and so what we've
done has created along this kind of
investment plane if you will that runs
from here to there these sets of
institutions and organizations and
instruments so you have grants down
there
yeahmaybe program would investing here
you have full market made investing up
there and this understanding of value
has actually worked pretty well for most
of the people in the game right it's
created phenomenal wealth for a lot of
folks it's done really good my whole
career has been spent somewhere along
most of your assistants spent there as
well and the problem though is that it's
fundamentally the wrong way to think
about value this is wrong there's
nothing right about this bifurcation
because at the end of the day you cannot
disaggregate value you cannot take value
and pull it apart and say that as a
business person you can rape pillage and
philanthropy then somehow that's okay
then you can somehow take your grant
dollars and do good because you did so
bad when you were making your economic
value over here as a nonprofit it's not
good enough to say well we raised a lot
of money we gave a lot of money away we
did a lot of charity because it's not
about charity it's not about social
impact it's about leverage and maximum
full value impact and that's the issue
and as you'll see as I kind of dissect
this I have major issues around how
foundations are managing how nonprofits
are run or on just this point because at
the end of the day the value really
resides up here it's fully integrated
it's fully embedded in itself you can't
tease it apart it's really as this graph
so clearly illustrates no
it's really in this quadrant this is
actually from the paper that I did when
I was at HBS so it's a little like bent
in terms of the jargon and stuff but the
basic idea is yeah you know yeah social
and you have economic that are
fundamentally like reinforcing each
other like this and then all that takes
place within this sheath of
environmental value that you can't pull
yourself out of right so like your mom
knew this stuff I mean which he used to
like send you off to school and she'd
have you out at the door and you having
a little backpack and everything you'd
be all ready to go
she didn't lean down over you and say no
I want you to be the richest little
venture capitalist you can be didn't say
that she said you know take care of your
allowance don't beat up your sister and
when you get home walk duck so mom knew
okay be smart in terms of how you manage
your economic assets and value don't
beat up your sister you're part of a
social context and contract and you need
to provide for others in the same way
that you provide for yourself and walk
the dog obviously take care of the
planet you don't don't don't do this
kind of thing don't ruin things and so I
think you know going back to Alice
comment this morning about the value
speck I'm sorry the light spectrum I
think of it in terms of value and value
is fundamentally holds like the white
light that comes and hits the prism and
then it goes like and there's all kind
of ways that you can think about it but
the way that we tend to think about it
in current kind of conceptual framing
it's like right here it's only that
stuff then we can actually document and
track because we've convinced ourselves
that if we can document and track it
somehow we can manage it right you can't
manage what you can't measure right
I just don't believe that for a minute
we can take that last line out of there
probably but
and I think nobody doubts that
microwaves exist right ultraviolet
x-rays gamma I mean all this stuff is
fundamentally there when you're a
business manager then you launch an
enterprise you're creating you know
great economic value
you're also employing people you're
paying taxes you're taking resources out
of the planet and hopefully not just you
know putting waste back in I mean
there's a whole set of value
implications for what you're doing that
never represented on the balance sheet
or your cash flows game or any of these
things because we believe in this thing
called externalities right so as a
business you can set up your your books
and you can do all this stuff and half
the value more than half the value I
would argue that you're actually engaged
in creating the managing never
represents itself on your bow streets or
any of the metrics that we use
traditional something is wrong with that
equation this is from I actually stole
this from John Elkington it does the
triple bottom line work and it's from
shell from one of their annual reports a
couple of years ago and I think it's
really interesting because what they're
saying in this report is that the value
that we're creating as a company is not
even a function of the triple bottom
line it's a function of how those
elements interact over time to create
the full value of the firm that's the
blended value proposition and it's it's
interesting to watch how its kind of
morphing out into a lot of these ways
and it's not so much gosh you know it's
you know it's jazz language and I'm
trying to convince people that this is
the way to think about this it's
fundamentally what is happening out
there I don't have to do anything this
is the great thing about my job all you
have to do is sit back and watch these
processes evolve and help people kind of
connect the dots because it's really
happening out there right now today and
it has a lot of implications it has
implications for how we think about the
role of the fiduciary and in this
context I mean I have another paper that
it's going up on the generation website
a couple weeks on fiduciary trustees and
being a responsible trustee and what
that means but in this context I'm
really thinking of it as some kind of
integration of a financial and lifetime
fiduciary because I think the way that
you think about how you manage
why facets is as important as the wage
Krusty is thinking about how they manage
financial assets and we need to just
recognize that it has implications for
how we organize our work but as
implications for how we think about the
nature of the firm in essence occasions
for capital attract and you can read all
that stuff yourself in terms of the
fiduciary responsibility piece if you're
managing assets for long term value you
have to think about those assets
differently than if you just manage them
for a short term kind of in-and-out
performance and if you think about your
life I would argue that you have to
think about managing your life for that
long-term piece you know the great job
that you can get today that really
jeopardizes what it is that you entered
in your gut really want to do and feel
called to do is it really such a great
job even if in terms of your career
track and what it is that your your
profession or whatever says that you
should be doing it's a great job and I
personally had to deal with this a year
ago when I was approached by a guy who's
like a famous tech guy and he was like
look I'm gonna operationalize all this
stuff we're gonna do a fully unified
investment strategy we're gonna take our
philanthropy our mainstream investing
they're a new business development and
we're gonna manage it all as one
initiative around value creation right
and we want you to come and work on this
with us and help us kind of do this
right this is it the guy's giving me
like the keys in the Ganga right and I
was like well okay but I need to be able
to work at a Colorado part-time because
I have this other thing going right and
I'm trying to get integration I don't
want to get this whole thing together
and he couldn't do it and I had to walk
from that job without generation or
anything else on the back end and it
scared the hell out of me I mean it
really did because here I am I'm living
up in the high country no visible means
the support and I'm kind of like oh my
god you know like how could I do this
right and as I thought of that how how
could I do this right there's just no
way because it would have it would have
put me right back on that track of
having this phenomenal career path and a
really crummy personal life and quite
frankly it's just saying worth it it's
just not worth it but any event so
managing your resources and your assets
for the long-term peace and
understanding that the value that gets
created is again this integration of
kind of like the you know the value of
the firm
in the capital but also the personal
investment that you're putting into that
and that you need to be managing that
over time because what will happen is
you get into these companies and these
firms whether they're nonprofit or
for-profit and it's really again a
matter of understanding that the point
is not necessarily to maximize financial
or social value but from a value
creation perspective the whole idea of
nonprofit and for-profit really doesn't
matter because nonprofits create
economic value of Worth and so end war
profits have social environmental impact
some value as well and so the question
is really how do you help each type of
institution whatever kind of legal or
institutional structure it finds itself
within how do you help that institution
maximize the full value potential that
it has I mean one of the things that I
think about is the affordable housing
industry in this country where look 15
years ago 20 years ago we had we still
have you know major issues around
affordable low cost housing so we've
created the affordable housing tax
credit and all these Community
Development Corporation's came into
being using that as a financing
mechanism to build all this affordable
housing in the United States and that
that's a great track record of success I
take nothing away from the affordable
housing community the problem I have is
most of that housing was built with
clear-cut lumber so here are these folks
who say we care about community we care
about you know people we're good people
right we're the good guys we're the
social housing people right and yet what
they're doing is in their pursuit of
their pure social mission they're
creating this evaluation in terms of
environmental impacts all they had to do
was not think of themselves in the
social work or the social kind of
framework but think of themselves as
value creators and they could have gone
into timid timber industry and said look
we've just created this whole new
financing mechanism that's gonna create
a whole new market for your products and
what we want to do is contract with you
guys to provide sustainably harvested
timber for these products and that's
what how we're gonna drive this and you
could combine the economic value
potential that those institutions had
with the social impacts that they have
created and create greater in the
aggregate value than you would then they
have I'd argue by doing one or the other
and I think that there are examples like
that just straight down the line in
terms of how we
about value in these organizations and
the point is that again the focus
shouldn't really be on whether you're
nonprofit or for-profit the focus needs
to be on how you maximize the really the
impact or the potentially relationships
in order to have the greatest value
creation potentially you can so on the
flip side of that then you've got these
organizations and institutions you also
then have the capital markets that are
kind of driving some of this performance
in and not even a good a good way and I
think that in the past we've seen you
know really this kind of you know the
breakouts bifurcation of the value piece
where you make money here and you give
it away over there and increasingly
you're seeing that getting called into
question you're seeing people who are
really saying that in fact you can take
economic instruments you can take
investing instruments and you can create
social environmental value as well as
financial performance and return and the
issue is more one of how do you
structure that how do you play in this
middle space now in another shtick I do
I've got this whole thing where I break
down all these different examples of
blended value investing which is like
this space in between kind of pure
philanthropic and pure market rate
investing practices and I want to go
through that now but just to say that
not only the United States but around
the world more and more investor groups
you're coming together to do this to
actually engage in this practice where
they want to see effective application
of their financial resources and assets
in the same way that at the same time if
they're actually creating social
environmental value it's going to take a
second and kind of blow through a couple
these so you have some idea but one of
them is the acumen fund which actually
started out they still receive
philanthropic support but they started
out making grants to organizations that
we're doing different things on a ton of
an enterprise basis and they've now
moved through loans and now they're
doing almost pure equity plans who these
organizations an example that is seek
them in Egypt which is basically a
cooperative of organic farmers and their
investment they did a $350,000
investment there was a combination kind
of a blended structure instrument of
long and equity that allowed them to
expand from 426 to 860 they have an
annual growth rate this past year that
obviously is not itself sustainable but
they did 35 percent growth over that
time and they were
again create real value here now my
question is what kind of value is it
it's fundamentally it's real economic
value these people are making money
they're growing into new markets they're
getting a financial return for their
participants in the cooperative there
they are by definition creating an
environmental value because we're
basically teaching people how to do
organic agriculture so that's that's of
worth and has value and they're also
then having a direct effect on the
families that are part of this
cooperative structures right so you
Tommy right I mean it's kind of like
this is the issue in terms of how we
think about the nature of value when it
comes to capital think about Shore Bank
Pacific who are basically FDIC insured
sustainable banking institution for CDs
money markets savings accounts I mean
very traditional kind of instruments and
offerings for folks as a foundation if
you buy CDs from shore bank and you opt
to take the below-market way to return
you get PRI credit for that so it counts
toward your social mission as well as
how you manage your assets and then what
they do is they take these resources and
they reel end them in the regional basis
to support sustainable business
development in the northwest what kind
of value is that means full blended
value finally Merrill Lynch Community
Development Corporation 800 million
dollars in CDC type lending and equity
their performance as a fund
zero losses on their loans in less than
1/2 1% of equity is performing a subpar
basis so that's pretty good and they're
basically returning that investment back
to their I'm sorry they're returning
that financial return to their investor
group so so that's one whole set of
players in the capital space a lot of my
work has been around the foundation
community and really beating these
people up because if you think about the
way that most foundations are managed it
really doesn't make any sense
most foundation people think of
themselves as grant makers they think
our job is to provide grants to the
nonprofit sector so what they do is they
manage their corpus so it can have that
payout and most of them and most
foundations try to drive for a 5 percent
payout because that's the the regulated
piece and they don't really do much more
above that although they can certainly
opt to do that if they want to the
that is twofold what is that if you look
at capital flows in the nonprofit sector
the philanthropic community represents
lesson three two to three percent of the
total capital flows in the sector so the
idea that the foundation community is
going to have a significant impact
through its grant making just doesn't
make any sense to me because they're
just they're not even really a major
player in terms of how money actually
moves through that space if they really
want to have an impact they need to
think about their assets in a different
way they need to think about the
intellectual assets they bring to the
table they can think about how they can
help build a field of practice they can
think about lobbying and other
activities in terms of public policy we
can think about the whole transparency
and engagement with the field and really
modeling different practices and
obviously they can think about their
grant making in a more effective
strategic way the other problem I have
with the foundation community is that as
a quasi kind of business investment and
again it makes no sense to me that you
would create an institution that takes
five percent of its assets to drive 100
percent of its mission and keeps 95
percent of its assets to pursue nothing
wait at best you're neutral and it works
you may actually be investing on the 95
percent in creating and contributing to
the problems that you claim to be
concerned about addressing with your 5%
and I just think it's really wrong it's
a wrong way to think about asset
management and it's the wrong way to
think about value creation for me I
think you know one of the better
examples is the Nathan cuttings
Foundation which is a great organization
great people like Carol Williams who was
their treasurer was getting ready for
boarding and she was going to report in
to the board on the whole set of
investments they were making and was
also going to report in on some of the
grants that run to consideration and she
was looking at like the two reports and
she saw that they had a eight hundred
seventy five thousand dollar investment
they were making in Smithfield Foods
which is a great you know act on
business does great returns and all that
stuff happens to engage in a lot of hog
farming in the Midwest um very good
route and then she looked on the grass
sheet and they were making an eight
hundred thousand dollar grant to a
nonprofit in the Midwest to address the
negative effects of hog farm
and it's kind of like at the end of the
day something's wrong your tits right
now what they decided to do is we're not
going to do anything of screening we're
gonna actually make the investment and
use the relationship the shareholder
relationship to engage management and
try and work with them around how to
look back to their supply chain so that
there's better practices all the way
along so there's a lot of different
answers and I'm not arguing that there's
one way to go with any of this right all
I'm arguing is that if you're really
managing for value and you have assets
under management whether your own life
assets or physical assets or whatever it
is you need to think in terms of how do
you maximize the full impact and so from
a foundation perspective all I'm asking
for is a unified investment strategy
that basically says when we think about
the grants that we're making and these
grants each carrying like higher levels
of social risk if you will for the type
of grant that you're actually engaged in
complying but we think about those in
concert with how we're allocating the
rest of our assets and the actual
instruments that you're going to be in
the overall strategy and risk exposure
you're gonna carry them and all that is
going to look different for different
foundations in the same way that for any
investor depending on your risk
tolerance and what you're actually
trying to do you're going to create a
portfolio that reflects what it is that
you think will get you to the end goal
but the main thing is that it has to be
a unified approach we have to think
about this in that way which raises the
whole set of issues in terms of how we
understand tracking and performance in
the metrics themselves because we
fundamentally have this problem where
we've got this kind of we do a valuation
on the social stuff over here we have F
ROI financial analysis econometrics over
here and the problem is we don't really
have a good way to talk about this
middle space or to really drive managers
to perform in non economic or extra
economic I guess you could say
performance and and the thing that I
have with this one is that I mean I
think it's great again what people have
done in terms of double and triple
bottom line work and their reporting
practices and all that the problem is
that most of that doesn't get
reintegrated so when you release a
triple bottom-line report the social and
environmental people all flip to the
section that has like the social
mental elements and the faith's people
all turn to the metrics that are like
numeric okay and again my issue is that
there is a single non divisible bottom
line and we need to be taking forward a
set of first a framework and then a set
of metrics that allow us to actually
track performance over time and
understand that increasingly what's
happening is that in the corporate
community a lot of this stuff started
out simply as compliance stuff that they
did for Sheryl for stakeholders rather
so they were getting beat up about you
know you're doing this since in this
forest or you're doing this in terms of
how you treat your employees and so they
started just reporting out to people
externally with the Provost none of the
managers are driving any of that it's
the internal operations of the company
and shifting how they actually make
decisions in terms of how they manage
their firm and increasingly what I think
is happening is both for the nonprofit
variation of that you had out some
funding where basically you would start
spilling all of this data for
foundations and governmental entities
but you would never really use that to
inform how you develop your own program
or operations in the nonprofit context
and I think what's happening is that
increasingly you're seeing both
nonprofit and for-profit managers kind
of saying you know if we can tweak this
stuff and drive it down and to actually
highly run a company we can actually do
something different here we can we can
use it to inform how we manage and how
we make decisions in the course of the
work that we're engaged in so which this
raises then this whole set of issues
around how we understand knowledge
because what's happening is the the best
and emerging promising practice the
stuff that that's the best is not coming
from any of the silence it's not coming
from the nonprofit side and the social
advocates to put it up and it's not
coming from the business schools in the
academics or the the business managers
it's coming when you have like a
business person who bumps into a social
person and they start talking about like
what they're doing and they're kind of
like geez this is really kind of similar
when you talk to I mean for me this
really got written home when I was in a
meeting with the US Chamber of Commerce
in DC and I'm talking to these you know
white guys in suits and they were just
all white guys in suits it was classic
right but I'm talking these guys and
they were saying like well we think that
fundamentally you know what's you know
that mainstream
corporations create social value for
society and we don't feel that we're
getting adequately credited for that
value creation and then you go down the
street and you talk to the CBC community
and they're like we're creating economic
and social value and we're always viewed
as just asking for a handout right and
it's fundamentally they're both
grappling with the same issue and the
same shortfall and where they connect is
in the disc you know the
dysfunctionality of the existing
frameworks of practice so what's
happening is that the new knowledge
that's going to come forward comes as
you have folks who can simultaneously
occupy multiple spaces in this in these
networks and it comes out through the
creation of these kind of value networks
where people connect by trying to
explore common problems and challenges
and issues that they're having in the
course of their work and so it's the
value networks to transcend these silos
that really is where the action is going
to be over the coming years and it's
really where the action is right now you
see it in terms of different
internet-based
collaborative that people are engaged in
to try to solve some of these problems
whether from a capital or from an ask
for my organizational management piece
and again bring this back to the
personal journeys minute stuff I mean
it's like this is really where the
action is for each of us as individuals
right I mean increasingly you see
business people who cash out at 40 50 60
and go into the nonprofit sector
you see nonprofit people who go back and
get an MBA because they want to engage
in community good and you know social
value creation I mean people are like
morphing back and forth all the time in
this stuff and we need to have more
confidence in that journey and in the
fact that that morphing personally is
what will lead to community value and
corporate value over time cuz that's
really where the action is and quite
frankly just a lot more fun than sitting
in one little slot your entire life like
folks were you know often did in the
past so about three years ago a group of
us started talking about this issue and
we started thinking in terms of these
silos and with support from third nut
and from Hewlett and skull
and Packard a couple of other folks we
were able to basically do this
convenient process what we said is ok if
you're in one of these silos and you
wanted to drop into the other silo how
would you know like what's going on in
that space and so we brought people
together from these five areas and we
basically said
all right what are the key topics
resources resource organizations
initiative leadership examples and
issues and discussion within your silo
and how would you define that who do you
point to when you try to tell somebody
about what it is you do that's kind of
thing so we put all that together into
one kind of map thing but then what we
said was what we're really interested in
though is this like one of the
challenges and the issues that are that
are holding you back and what we found
is that in fact if you look at these
silos they're all talking about issues
of capital they're talking about issues
of performance measurement metric
they're talking about how do you create
an enabling environment that can help us
move this forward they're all talking
about the same thing so on the one hand
this is all really really great as you
tell I get a ton of exciting ready on
the other hand it's really frustrating
because most of these people still think
of themselves as here and they don't
think of themselves as here much less
going out here to create the maximum
value of the day platoons potentially
could and so I think where this kind of
weaves up is kind of here where it's
like we're all walking on these paths
going into these meadows right and you
can almost kind of make out what's there
I mean you can almost taste this stuff
it's so close I swear to God but we're
not there okay we're just not there
and I can yell from here and somebody
over here can't even really hear me very
well and and this is really the game is
to try to see can we really work
together so with the mist and the fog
and do something kind of different and
so in my case what I'm trying to do is
just stay connected to different people
who are doing really cool stuff now I
told somebody that I was gonna put my
email address up here and they said I
was just that was just insane okay
because I already have real problems
managing my email but basically what
I've also done this Tracy mentioned was
launch the blog which I understand is
kind of sometimes works and sometimes
doesn't so I got to fix that but the
basic idea is instead of like sending me
emails which I get sometimes from
students saying I'm doing a paper on X
can you help me find Y in which case
I'll send an email back saying go read
the map that's why we did the map have a
good time I'm interested in you know in
that impact in this network there are
folks who are all over this stuff
musicians who are basically learning
about every single day like the best way
to think about this they're coming on an
organization that's doing that or are
actually like housed within different
institutions that are trying to grapple
with various parts of that big picture
issue and none of us I don't think have
the bandwidth to really appreciate or
track that the richness of
experimentation and knowledge that
actually is being brought forward and so
what I've been doing is just kind of
connecting with folks through the blog
or through the blended value website and
just personally to try to really explore
some of this stuff and track what's
going on in a more effective way another
example that is this magazine that we're
gonna be watching at the Davos in 2006
called valium and this is just a mock-up
but the basic idea is to try to create a
place in the magazine context where you
can kind of represent this stuff out and
where you can bring people together to
talk about these Crosscut's not the
silos but the cross-cutting themes and
issues and you can really like give us a
platform for this and the content for
the magazine is going to be driven by a
group of folks probably you know 50 to
100 people initially who will be brought
together by John Elkington and myself to
basically begin to explore how to drill
down on these cross-cutting themes and
how to really keep that kind of
conversation dialogue going the other
thing that's happening is one of the
reasons I'm out here is to is to create
a capital mapping network in the same
way that I get tired of people using the
blur word if I hear one more person talk
about the need to map the capital space
so that we can understand how to connect
this type of organization or institution
with this type of capital I'm just gonna
die right I mean there's got to be like
seven of these things going on right now
in different parts of the world and so
what we're basically proposing is look
everybody just go ahead and do
everything that you were gonna do anyway
but let's just tell each other like
what's happening and let's let's try to
coordinate our stuff so that if I'm
focused on emerging markets venture
capital here you know how can i connect
that with second or third tier kind of
funding which is more kind of the kind
of blended value investing that I was
presenting in my state
you got folks who evolved in the World
Economic Forum the Bellagio sustainable
development forum and one other group
that is skating right now all three of
which are launched
mapping initiative so we're gonna try to
pull some of those together and again
the final part of that is the what else
piece because at the end of the day all
of this is just moving so fast and it's
so incredible and we need to be like
sharing that information more
effectively and connecting better on in
that regard so finally I guess the
closing thing would be just to say that
I think it's really important that
everybody like build organizations stay
really grounded at what it is that your
call to do and how you understand that
for where you are at any given point in
time and at the same time I think it's
really really important that you do that
work with your head like way out here
because if you really think that your
organization your building is like it
and that's the point it's just wrong
wait I mean I know teachers aren't
supposed to say that but I mean it's
just wrong I mean you know the whole
point of doing any of this is to advance
something else bigger more better and if
the legacy you leave are sets of
institutions that help move that agenda
great but the goal is not to create more
institutions when I finished the mapping
process some of my some of the people
who had funded us said you know you
should create you know that the plenty
of value misses you so you can bring
people together to talk about this right
and I said that's exactly what we should
not do right because you don't need
another group to bring people together
for more meetings to talk about the need
to collaborate so instead what we do is
have more people kind of pushing within
their own organizations institutions to
really build these links and connections
and to really have passion about the
fact that that's what we're called to do
Billy the group is great developing the
community is great but it's the
connecting function that really is going
to get us where we need to go ultimately
and that's really like the key thing
it's like George Marshall was the guy
who did the Marshall Plan yeah al uses
this comment on this quote a lot but I
really like it basically you know here's
this guy in a world war two is going
around trying to convince all these
people to put up a ton of cash to
reinvest in Europe right and some of
those conversations went well a lot of
whom didn't right a lot of people were
like why should we do this and he spent
years just building momentum for that
single idea and one of his lives was to
say to these folks you know instead of
steering ourselves by the ships to our
side we need to steer ourselves by the
stars above and that's all I'm asking
for
so it's basically be connected to your
institution be connected to what your
call to do but do it within a context of
a greater vision about what this is all
about because it's not about money and
it's not about social and it's not about
environmental it's about maximizing the
full value potential each of us has to
create through the course of our lives
into the work that we're called to do so
thank you very much I appreciate your
patience